foreign
s us up next in Fort Worth Texas Zane
welcome to the show
are you with us saying Hey there you are
yes sir how's it going how can we help
good yeah well hey so I was calling my
wife and I are wanting to or we're
thinking about doing the baby steps
getting out of debt and all the stuff
um but the problem is I'm a real estate
agent and because of that my income's
not very consistent
and so the thousand dollar uh emergency
fund is seems kind of scary to us I
guess um there's some months where I
just don't make any money and in those
months uh my wife her income would still
leave us about three to four thousand
dollars short of our monthly bills hmm
so we're trying to figure out what what
should we keep in our bank account while
we're paying off debt so that we don't
uh on the months that I don't make money
that we don't go you know negative or
have to go in a day you know to try to
not be late on our bills
is there anything else that you can do
aside from the real estate to kind of
level out
level the playing field a little bit
there so that you're not so that the
pendulum is not swinging so far from one
side to the other
well I typically we just keep a large
Nest Egg
um we just typically keep 10 to 15 000
in savings because you know there's
going to be and there's always two to
three months out of the Year where I
just don't make money so that's what
we've done in the past it's worked
pretty well for us but uh
that's true but what I'm suggesting is
that you eliminate the two to three
months out of the year that you don't
make money
yeah
um I mean I I guess there's I could
maybe pick up a second job that's not
really something we want to do though
we've got little kids and we're both
already busy enough with our careers in
church and different things like that
well there's a level of sacrifice that
needs to be made for a season we're not
saying take on a side job forever nobody
wants to nobody's like man I just got so
much free time it's oh my gosh we got to
get our butts in gear we're in debt
we've been in debt for years what are we
doing and right now you guys have been
kind of comfortable coast and you got 10
to 15 in the bank you're like well we're
not in Crazy rush to get rid of the debt
we're gonna make it so how much debt do
you guys have
oh y'all are gonna laugh at me um
probably a little over a hundred
thousand probably closer to 110. I ain't
laughing I'm scared I'm crying what kind
of debt is this
um about so 50 000 in student loans uh
another 50 in car and then about about
five in credit cards and probably we
just had a baby not too long ago so I
think like six thousand more in the
medical debt
what's your household income
who so his wife and I together probably
close to 175 okay
well looking at the numbers there's
there's a glaring thing that we could do
today to clean up some of this debt and
you're not gonna like it
can you guess which one it is
I mean probably the cars I'd imagine
ding ding ding what kind of car is this
um so mine I have a Jeep Wrangler we
only owe about four or five on that we
could that's that's easy
um the other one is an expedition that
we just got last year what's that thing
worth
probably 50. and you owe what 45 on it
that's that's the silver That's the
Silver Bullet right there comes in to
sell that thing yeah let us come take
that off your hands Zane
do you see what what George is getting
at dude you just cleared half your debt
what's the payment on that expedition
Reds 812 a month if you had an extra 812
a month would you be as nervous having a
thousand bucks in an emergency fund
um well I'd still would leave us about
2200 short of everything because you got
a payments out of your eyeballs months
out of the year yeah see this is this is
this is what I don't like I'm just going
to be honest with you you called with
the issue George just freed you up a
good chunk of money but that's an excuse
you put an excuse in there he's solving
your problem for you and you can't say
yeah but you've got to go okay that gets
me one step closer what's the next thing
I gotta do okay that gets me Next Step
Closer what's the that's the type of
attitude we need here Zane to get this
done you've got to be looking at this
going all right great check what's next
okay good I'll do that I'll do whatever
it takes to clear this debt that's where
you've got to be right now and I I think
George was right before you guys were
coasting and you were just going along
and now you're gonna have to really put
the pedal to the metal and you're gonna
have to you're gonna feel this there's
no getting out of a 100K of debt without
feeling it and without it hurting you go
down to a thousand bucks you're like
I'll take four jobs tomorrow
you need that fire the thousand dollars
was never meant to be enough it wasn't
enough back in 1992 when Dave came up
with it right hvacs cost more than that
even back then yeah the point of a
thousand bucks was to get your button
gear cover the ankle biters and put a
fire under your butt so you go oh my
gosh we're not okay because America
thinks they're okay when they have 10
000 in the bank but a hundred thousand
in debt yeah and I'm going oh my gosh
I'm freaking out over the hundred
thousand yeah that that nest egg that
you have sitting there I think you said
you like to keep 15K or whatever that's
kind of lulled you to sleep on this is
that what you have in savings right now
15K
um a little more probably closer to 20
right now okay so think about this Zayn
for one second you would clear the
medical debt the credit card debt and
the Jeep just like that today right now
add up all those payments how much what
does that add up to five six hundred
bucks
that you were paying on those
see
yeah yeah just about now we sell the
Expedition boom we just cleared another
800 bucks so now we're up to what 1300
up from where we were you get a side job
making an extra 700 a month now we're 2
000 up
now all that's left is student loans
when we start crushing those and that
thing's gone you're making 180 and
you've got a 50 000 student loan it's
gone in what eight months probably
with your income
yeah well that's probably doable and
then I'm up in my my marketing game with
referrals with real estate I'm going I'm
about to sell some houses
do you see that saying that's exciting
in a year's time
your life is totally different
now you're not the one who has to go to
my wife and tell her to sell the car but
yeah oh yeah you're right you're right
we don't have to be there for that
you'll be strong though because she's if
you lay it out the way that we just
showed you literally the way that George
just said it you write these sit down
with her tonight and say hey man I've
been thinking uh don't say hey man say
love of my life I've been I've been
thinking about this and and write this
out and lay out that plan and say do you
understand what we'd be able to
accomplish and really make sure that
you're playing up you know you guys
goals and your dreams for the future
this is an offer that few could refuse
am I right George I mean you lay out the
vision not just tomorrow because
tomorrow sucks tomorrow we get we
amputate the Tahoe right amputate the
expedition in this case but think about
what three years from now
three years from now most people who
don't follow this stuff are calling us
back going hey we're further in the hole
we thought having 10 000 in the bank was
going to save our butts and the interest
and the payments or further in debt or
three years from now you have no debt in
the world you have a fully funded
emergency fund you're maxing out your
retirement accounts and you drive cars
that are paid for um
that's a vision right there
and then you go hey honey if I don't
make money that month we're going to be
okay
yeah no that's that's the big reason we
don't owe people money and that's the
freedom that that's that's true Freedom
right there right now which all are
coasting on that's that's the fake stuff
that 15K that you're sitting on is fake
let's make it real have you guys been
through financial base universities
no uh our church just did it but I was I
was too smart to sign up
I figured out well hey I'm gonna give it
to you for free so that you can start a
class or join a class that's happening
in your area or online and we're going
to help you get your wife on board
because sometimes I know I'm not very
good at convincing my wife of any of
anything yeah but I'll tell you Dave
Ramsey he's quite the convincer and when
you watch those videos usually it takes
a lesson or two and all of a sudden
you're like I get it yeah I get it let's
do this and they get more amped up than
the spouse absolutely and I mean here's
the thing with them it's not even going
to take that long it's just making a
couple of key decisions locking it in
and just kind of grid and bear it is it
grin and Barrett grin and bear it for a
minute and and then you're through I'm
seeing a theme in today's show Jade
people that are making a hundred eighty
thousand dollars a year are broke
because everyone goes well Jade if I
just made more money nope you'd be the
next Zane yep you'd be the next Brad
calling in going I made great money I
just don't know where it's going man
paycheck to pay check it's going to
lenders making them Rich helping them
sponsor the next freaking Stadium
go into your Taquito fix at 7-Eleven
every day don't be a statistic
delayed gratification America look it up
get used to it it'll change your life